[Music]
Yasha monk author of the identity trap
writes this week's cover piece the West
he says doesn't know which side to back
in the war in Israel and Gaza to explain
Yasha joins me now Yasha you're right in
this week's magazine that the reaction
to the atrocities committed in Israel is
different to the reaction of those in
other count R tell us why yeah it's a
really striking contrast when you think
of the difference and reaction to
something like 9/11 in the world which
was big protest of solidarity with the
United States leamont titled we are all
Americans um in the aftermath of the
worst terrorist attack on Jewish life
since World War II the slaughter of over
1,400 people many of them babies
grandmothers by h
uh we didn't see anything like that um
Lamont talked about Israel's Lust For
Revenge um we saw plenty of protests in
the Streets of London and Paris and
Berlin and so on uh but they were uh
supporting uh uh the Palestinian course
but more specifically in many cases
glorifying those uh uh Hamas fighters
who who carried out that that murder now
part of that is of course this is one
particular uh episode in a broader uh
political conflict but is very
complicated and reasonable people can
have very different views about why for
example um we are so far from peace
today and that has I think led to a lack
of moral Clarity in some journalists who
want to complicate individual episodes
in this conflict um even if those are
morally absolutely clear you can have
different views about Isel Palestine you
should not be able to have different
views intellectually and morally about
the permissibility of this uh terrible
terrorist attack but there is also
something broader here and that is
rooted in a new ideology a new set of
ideas about race gender and sexual
orientation a new set of ideas about
Concepts like structural racism and
intersectionality and what it means to
be postcolonial that I trace in my new
book the identity trap and that I wrote
about in the magazine this week and you
write that this is grounded in the
changing nature of the left uh in the
ideas of being taught in universities in
the academy tell us about this kind of
intellectual development of this new
movement this new ideology as you put
it yeah so more broadly it's it's it's a
new set of ideas about the role that
identity categories do and should play
in our society um I call it the identity
trap because there's a lure here which
is to recognize the ways in which our
societies whether in the United Kingdom
or the United States or France or other
places are unjust um uh still do show
the signs of uh previous injustices in
particular and so these ideas claim to
be the most radical the most
uncompromising way to fight against
those injustices to Build a Better World
the problem is that they are a trap they
actually encourage the kind of zero some
conflict that as we're seeing in Israel
Palestine at the moment can lead to
terrible Bloodshed they're making it
harder rather than easier for us to
construct a peaceful and tolerant
society in which we have real political
solidarity with each other across the
lines of those groups now one of the
problems with it that ends up being
really relevant in this debate is that
it doesn't allow us to see the world
very clearly um you know uh many people
on the left have taken on an exclusively
structural understanding of racism in
which if you're part of a
supposedly uh uh marginalized group it
is impossible for you to have prejudices
against to be racist against a member of
a supposedly dominant group because
we've thrown the older conception of
racism based on individual bias
completely out of the window there's a
superimposition in a sort of strangely
neocolonial way of American racial
categories on everybody else so when
people analyze something like the Israel
Palestine conflict they try to fit Jews
into the box of white people and
Palestinians into the box of people of
color and so even though at this point a
plurality of Israelis are mrai Jews who
have thrown out of Middle Eastern
countries in violent ways over the
course of the last 75 years and have a
very similar skin tone to Palestinians
they are perceived as whites who are
part of this dominant group uh that
therefore cannot have bad things happen
to them and Palestinians are quoted as
people of color who therefore must be
justified in their resistance there's an
imposition of the categories of settler
colonies on Israel so that uh uh you
know Israelis are seen in the same way
in which uh um you know the Americans
who arrived in North America on the
Mayflower are seen as these kind of
outside settlers who come in even though
of course Jews trace the origins to the
Middle East to uh uh the territory of
today's uh uh Israel as to Palestinians
um and again a lot of a population are
people like Mahi Jews who flew from
Middle Eastern countries who did not
have anywhere else uh to go and so we're
seeing how these simplistic ways of
squeezing everything into identity
categories are not just making it harder
to understand the world but then result
in these very significant moral errors
like claiming that uh these terrorist
attacks are Justified because all
Israeli civilians are settlers who have
it coming to them basically yes and I
suppose in that answer there you talk
more about the Israelis and how they're
perceived but there's also quite a
patronizing undertone to how the
Palestinians are achieved in this I
suppose is that your argument is that a
lot of the Western View and Western
interpretation uh under this new
thinking produces quite a patronizing
account of how the Palestinian
authorities conduct themselves in a way
in which it almost excuses their agency
in all of
this yeah I
mean you know one of the elements we
haven't quite touched on is the concept
of
intersectionality which suggests that
all forms of Oppression are somehow
naturally linked um and so you have
these weird placards at many prop
Palestinian protest saying things like
uh you know Reproductive Rights depend
on Palestine or queers for Palestine um
and if you then point out um that
actually uh uh gay and despian in vaza
strip are sent to jail for 10 years uh
that Hamas openly just an islamist
organization all openly uh criminalizes
uh
homosexuality um then the Defenders of
that organization start to say
uh well but that isn't really the for of
Palestinians Owen Jones pointed out that
the first time that homosexuality was
criminalized was under the British
mandate uh uh you know decades ago this
is a great example of robbing
Palestinians of uh agency because just
as Britain changed its laws about
homosexuality in the you know 80 plus
years since the British mandate on
Palestine uh went away Hamas today would
be very open and very free and very able
to stop criminalizing
homosexuality uh if they felt like it
right to to ascribe this to uh sort of
the actions of British colonialists who
certainly have done bad things in the
world um is to pretend that Palestinians
don't have any agency today in exactly
the way that you point out and I've got
to ask I mean this Narrative of
intersectionality it's being pushed by
uh quiz for Palestine presumably
Palestine qu isn't pushing the reverse
and that this is basically just a
one-way Western narrative rather than
one which is reciprocated and returned
in kind by the
Palestinians yeah I think that's right
and what's what's sort of interesting
and strange about it is just how
simplistic that view of a world is um so
you know that concept of
intersectionality was coined by Kimberly
cran Shaw to make a sensible point which
is that the Discrimination for example
that a black woman might experience in
the United States is more than just the
arithmetic sum of the disadvantage faced
by white women on the one side and black
men on the other side and that I think
is true but the way that that concept
has then been interpreted is to go well
beyond that so say that if you stand at
a different intersection of identities
from me when I can't really understand
you uh that therefore all forms of
Oppression are linked and if you want to
be an activist in good standing on one
issue like environmentalism for example
you have to to defer to and accept the
political positions of all of these
other groups as well so to be a good
environmentalist you also have to have a
particular understanding of feminism and
you also have to have a particular
understanding of trans rights and you
also have to have a particular
understanding of uh What uh sort of a
right answer to the Palestine conflict
is um and you're right that that in a
strange way ends up going uh in one way
um but I think profound error is that
the world is just more complicated in
that that there can be uh groups that
are allies in one context and uh not
allies in another context um that groups
that uh perhaps have experienced real
disadvantage and marginalization in one
context nevertheless want to turn around
and oppress and marginalize others in a
different
context and you make the point of course
that we're going to see these Dynamics
only become more inflamed and
intensified in the coming weeks and you
referen in your piece this letter signed
by um 1700 sociologists so you expecting
that as the conflict continues and
potentially we've discussed elsewhere on
this uh show about having ground
Invasion do you think this is only going
to become more and more of a theme in
the West's left
arguments yes I feel so I mean we've
already seen how this conflict has uh uh
not just uh claim for lives of a lot of
uh innocent people in in Israel and in
Gaza
um but and this is less important but
significant nevertheless we've seen how
it's led to uh these very nasty fights
in in britam United States and and and
and
elsewhere um you know we've seen
institutions uh respond in a very
cowardly way um to the initial Hamas
attack uh you know American universities
in particular that have gotten in the
habit over the course of the last five
years of commenting on anything that's
happening in the world of condemning
anything that they dislike suddenly for
conspicuously silent uh when the worst
massacre of Jews since the Holocaust
took place um and then when these
institutions uh were forced by public
pressure to make statements about this
as they have about everything else there
was a huge counter-reaction I mean
hundreds and thousands of um uh students
and and faculty members fting their
University for speaking out in this kind
of way um and uh I feel that as the the
conflict in the Middle East looks Set uh
to escalate um uh that uh war on campus
and in many other institutions is going
to escalate as well yesha thank you so
much for joining us on spectator TV
[Music]
today